noon and welcome once again to the
weekly Android developer office hours
this is your emea edition coming to you
in the middle of the afternoon in lovely
sunny or almost sunny in London UK where
I am visiting from Munich and am joined
by my local cohorts rich at Nick and
Matt and also joined by Roman from New
York New York we are here to take on any
and all questions related to Android
development so let's see what's going on
yeah as usual we won't be making any
announcements on roadmaps future product
releases things like that so please
don't ask because we'll just save them
if you want to join the hangout live
come in and ask questions then please
just comment on the thread on the plus
android developers google+ page I don't
had you in and you can tell the last
night if if not at the question is in to
be the moderator or onto the thread
directly will answer them live on here
so we might as well get started we do
actually have one person live in the
Hangout already you'll see hi if you
actually have a question hey yo see ya
two questions first of all about the
Play services API and all the jar and
when it should come out and we can use
it fly me if you can have an answer for
that and secondly about fragments but it
can wait until you answer the first one
well the answer to the Play services API
questions pretty quick because that is a
future program question we don't have an
answer for you right now we can't commit
to that so if you just move on to the
fragrance will likely help me with that
one okay um I'm trying to do a fragment
a dialogue fragment and it should be a
pop up above our to paint fragments and
I want the the view to stop to waitin
too so the user can and select the
account you need it you know I wanted to
do something like that select the google
account but if i'll do the
down fragment it continues to the next
fragment and won't wait is there any
option to hold the UI until the user
wait for the selection what's the best
option to do it it can even rephrase the
part of the question we're saying it
goes on to the arcane i'll try i'm
trying to use a account manager to get
all the google accounts and show a
pop-up screens for the user to choose
which google account i can use to do off
with the API and okay sorry about that
we just dropped out for secondary okay
should I repeat the question again yeah
if you don't like yeah okay from the
start I'm using the account manager to
do off for my application to get all the
contacts from the google besides the
same point so the user will get a pop up
with an italic fragment saying which
google account who wants to use or maybe
add a new one and then the next fragment
should be when where I'm scraping out
the entire address book or contacts but
the problem is when I'm popping out the
first fragment I'm getting and
simultaneously moving forward to the
next fragment and I want to know what
what should I do
the UI thread right i mean the the
dialogue fragment awesome like the
interaction with the lock button also
happens on UI thread you know in before
fragments will you do is probably you
have a separate activity don't have a
dialogue theme yeah basically the
activity underneath it would be in the
started but pause state so just and I
don't answer the question straight on
here because I think it may depend on a
couple of things but what I would do is
instead of using a dialogue all together
I'd have a kind of a first step there
will be a full screen activity or full
screen fragment in that activity that
will let you select that account once
you select an account he goes on to the
next activity or just you know pops the
account selection fragment from the core
layout and shows the next ride so it
basically my short answer to this would
be don't use a dialog fragment just use
a an inline account selection private
and you guys have any other stuff okay
is there like a is there a reason you
aren't doing that is early kind of just
a what I'm trying to do is make a more
generic approach because I want to make
and the user options to be like I can
choose the google account i can choose a
twitter account i can choose a facebook
account and so on and so on and i'm
going to economist you're getting all
the counts by types and each time i'm
popping out the selector for all the
appropriate accounts and user can also
add the new account according to the
type who chose but then when i'm popping
on the dialogue sometimes it just
doesn't wait to kill the user select and
just moves on to the next selector to
the freshman and what I did was divided
the dialogue to two options and then
popped up the window with
Donald fragment and just waited until
the return from the OAuth and then I
moved on but it's not so good because
sometimes you need you see the the UI
thread Hanks for a bit and that's why I
wanted to know if there's any other
options to do it yeah I mean just in
case i don't know if i follow this
entirely but just in case you're kind of
assuming that there's blocking involved
but when you pop of the dialogue
fragment but kind of that's that's going
to block the the function that triggered
the dollar driver that called the show
method that that doesn't actually block
so what I was doing instead is I mean
assuming you have to use a Dalek
fragment like I said earlier probably
shouldn't is a dialogue in this case but
assuming you had to do it you you
shouldn't wait on you shouldn't have
kind of or assume any sort of blocking
operations just use a series of
callbacks so when the don't actually add
the next fragment until you get the
callback that these are yeah that's what
I did eventually but I wanted to know
there is a better option than that
because like sometimes when you get to
call backing you see the dialogue still
hangs about a half a second until you
get to the new fragment and so on so
that's why I wanted to be a bit more
precise on the UI and not be lit so much
for thanking yeah I mean if it's hanging
it might be immaculate here you're
blocking you I said with something like
off the top of my head I can't ago yeah
I'd probably instrument that and try and
find out what's going on during that so
users hist race across the Straits
crispy find out what's going on during
that time improve it okay yeah it fits
in dialogue frag me you may want to file
a bug or if you know you're not doing
anything yourself on the UI thread the
dialogue is hanging on the screen for
half a second it sounds like it might be
a bug somewhere and are you want to make
sure you move all the logic like on the
cliq handle on the dialogue so the first
painters is hide it and any like it's
nostalgic that happens also the cliq
happens like in the callback so if you
know there's nothing nothing stopping
this yeah i'm doing an ass kicked ass
condom
on the call back so the call that
returns to the holder activity and then
it triggers an event about a half a
second that's why I'm trying to save
that's the real that's the real issue
here okay that's nice yeah thanks thank
you cheers thanks for coming in today by
my nana during that question we've also
be enjoyed by Alex Lucas some other guy
in Zach Galifianakis right any one of
those names people answer to so feel
free to ask questions and it as well
what that means what are your special
subjects Alex oh I like Android before
Android i was on the analytics team so I
covered a lot of stuff on implementing
analytics in Android also accessibility
and just general framework key questions
excellent safety when asked questions
for android android android android
android or google TV please jump in hey
crusher really nice people um yeah feel
free to jump in I'll have a look quick
look on the threat come on your feet
from one holiday we usually have quite a
lot of questions on the thread pineap--
holiday today it is angel yes in bar
area in the very this is something I
today's assumption day also a makeover
on assumptions also know very human ok
in which case let's have a look through
some of the moderator questions yes ah
the first moderator question is asking
about something I've future product reef
such an athlete when will be we be able
to add our own location providers yeah
um can well I think I believe and I
haven't verified this myself haven't
created a sample have to do it but I
believe that if you check the allow mock
locations check box somewhere in your
system you can actually install
third-party providers having said that I
don't know what the api's are to do some
ways that I'll
somewhere in the wrong chat initiations
about yeah I mean the reason being like
I mean you don't want just any app to
willy nilly add like a fake GPS provider
right because then you know any apps
that rely on GPS or whatever for for
example you know geofencing or you're
making sure the content is restricted by
geography um if somebody's using that
then you basically get fake results so I
believe that's why it's hidden behind or
disabled by default and enable for
development purposes having sure that I
honestly don't know how to create a
provider one of the emulator tiles kind
of fake provider because it needs to let
you specify GPS coordinates many me but
yeah there's gotta be an API somewhere
if not then death know you were
definitely right out about the developer
options because there it is and felter
up yeah developer options and settings
we should probably double check if there
is an API I mean you probably extend the
location provider having said that I
don't know how you would register one
yeah I don't look a great guy that
exists hmm maybe I should dust off my
old Bluetooth GPS puck mmm excellent ok
the next question on the moderator is
how can I create an add-on dictionary
I'm bilingual and find that anything
I've type in my other line with this
alternative edited this is very
frustrating find the options in language
input android keyboard add-on
dictionaries anybody have an addiction
add-on i turn down a couple alternative
languages just for typing input but
we're really the ones that came stock
with the system its food we go to where
he says the personal dip hearing you
handed one would you be able to still
type in a different language and
keyboard look at which one you'll
bankfull i do tell it which one you want
to switch to so there's a little globe
icon yeah i'll add on dictionary service
make sure it's on the text correction Oh
you know this may be a new API either
ice cream sandwich or jelly bean over
here this may be noon so one way you
could do it it's just assuming this is
new because for example the emoji that
was never there before then here we go
that's definitely chillin man so if it's
new I probably just take a look at the
API diff between jelly bean and ice
cream sandwich just to say I mean I
don't know if we should do it now you
guys want clear plans probably have time
yeah but so let's take a look at it in
the background once we go to next
question yeah it's gone to the LT we're
gonna come back and continue are you
keeping researching live on the air yeah
it's just that kind of crap okay have
you considered this is from Canada in
teesside have you considered making
developers for android com a community
editable like quickie I said yeah I've
thought about it it's not about it what
do you think it it's hard I mean besides
which we already have something like
that there's there's like sec
overflowing many other sites like it we
have art form as well so we do have a
very hard working dedicated team of tech
writers
oh wow check this out sorry about that
they just dropped off a hangout Jules
free Peter for a second I think I don't
know i think that actually it's it's a
when you actually have something that
has a definitive right and wrong and you
have somebody who is making it
definitively right or wrong it kind of
makes a lot of sense for them to be the
ones due to document that yeah I can
understand why you want it as well
because there are things in the
documentation to get out of date and
people file bugs and we update them and
things and it'd be good to have more man
power behind it as a Spartan says here
it is nice to have the definitive guide
there and we do that other sources on
the google groups like overflow etc
minna mention say yeah an action
something about the add-on dictionary
you
okay provider of user-defined words for
input methods to use for predictive text
input applications and input methods may
add words into the dictionary so it
seems like this will just add something
to your existing dictionary so you can
create an app that's basically just if
you have 24 x you wanna do that yeah
just kind of like an add-on dictionary
manager maybe even imports things from
the cloud or what not respond right a
sample ever in a new class for that that
sounds good pretty good idea even
already have a dictionary sample hmm we
already have a dictionary sample we
could extend it yeah but there's no
probably something that's that's
specific to jelly bean and I haven't
found a hit oh well yeah that's probably
all we could say it is funny okay
okay hmm I want to take a look at that
online how was that I was go see a
google.com bug tracker for Android
handle oh is that the one we're not
talking about or the other here this one
yes Gary there are tons of very very old
issues that are now maybe not even are
not now even assigned others are fixed
but the ticket is still open yes well
curating multiply me curating the bug
trackers that we have internal to the
company's hard enough let alone curating
ones that are that are external facing
as well with you know two or three or
five or seven hundred thousand users all
wanting to contribute their own bugs the
best way if there's a boat on the public
tracker that you want us to get a better
look at it is to link to it and make
sure that it gets voted in start a lot
so that it'll sort of float to the top
of the sidebars we don't necessarily go
I'd agree to the bug so much is the
importance of the bug and the number of
stars that the bug receives the rest is
the domain metric that we use for that
yeah definitely look for look for a
question that already touches on what
you want and I'll put that rather than
forking anyone i will say also that uh
they I
believe that that list actually does
influence our development course in some
cases I suspect that a large part of the
reason why we made such leaps and bounds
of improvement in bi-directional text to
put 44 Ice Cream Sandwich and jelly bean
was because of those bugs that had SAT
up at the top of the queue and we
planted thousands and thousands of Orcs
right and there was not thousands and
thousands of bugs saying the same thing
it was a couple of bugs one thousands
and thousands of hours yeah so
reconciling bugs we fix internally with
ones that have been raised externally is
also tricky people trying to but
obviously the Android team of fixing
quite a lot of boats with each release
and they can't go through the entire bug
tracker seeing it's always actually
raised that X Emily and then closing it
off so there are definitely bugs in the
track of that a fixed won't take mr.
lucky okay ask someone's asking whether
they can ask a question yeah you can
let's go we love you toooo many of these
ask the question on media api's lie but
we'll see what we can do I don't really
here to answer questions exhibit we I
know it's a really bad question mostly
don't know we've got a new question is
pumped in Jaime create an app which will
play videos from YouTube and show
external subtitles for the plague video
can you please advise me on how to start
or if it's even possible oh yeah there's
a talk that Google i/o which is about
doing just this then there's a new
player library which it allows you to
embed YouTube videos I think do
subtitles a lot right by YouTube library
so this yeah those announced tonight
available it's not a guess it's not yet
available to keep an eye on
developers.google.com this little work
around four right maro our YouTube
videos and capture using the web to
embedded web view most people yeah it's
not over uh that'll were actually
that'll probably rely on flashlight or
is it gonna use html5 H came out fine
for my eyes and five in what uses
injured through point O or higher it's
not great experience really I
so it wouldn't be worth this point go
down the path like riding that because
this layer eight guys coming out yeah
this whole time it sort of captions i'm
not sure if it supports a list of what
we had a nice yet so yeah right I know
whether there's a difference between
turning on captions in the interview
ported and like getting a feed of the
captions I can display next to it and
your UI yeah let's just uh let's table
this question until that libraries
released it was announced hey there
before we move back to the moderator
we've got Roy Walley join us that's how
you pronounce your name happy yeah okay
have you got a question for us today or
if you just come in to say hello hi yes
yes we hear you so are you uh are you
doing Android development at the moment
there is there somewhere yeah yeah 300
developments yay Nigeria yeah I'm
developing on under the materiality
application using the Android platform
using camera location services also
great any questions or technical
questions or best practices questions or
anything no no notnot are demanding i
just came to learn to see what's up yeah
ok I don't know well thanks for dropping
in just feel free to stay down mm-hmm if
you do have any questions just shut up
moderator is now complete the thing with
a listen to be one more somewhere in
there oh yeah could you recommend a
sample project to demonstrate the
low-level media API the best thing at
the moment would be the YouTube videos
again the YouTube video from google i/o
this year on the low-level api's has
loads of samples and it in sample code
you have to do it also at the top of the
classes for media codec in the api doc
there's a bunch of sample code in there
as well i'll try and post the link to
that with do
I have another question if you can
answer wake of it that's here okay um
making a widget home screen widget and
the main issue is when sometimes you do
a pending intent if you want to do a non
click on the view so you go back to the
activity but stumps sometimes it happens
that you click on the widget you go back
to the application and you go back and
forth for some like four or five clicks
and then when you click again on the
widget on the home screen you get an
exception that you cannot send the
pending intent you tell you why is give
anymore these days ah that's the only if
you want I can try and see the second
you gave me is this happening during
development or with the production
version of the app same time it doesn't
influence if its own production or not
but the main issue is here it's I'm
trying to make a distinct unique intent
each time I click on the button so it
won't happen again and after the going
back and forth from the contact but just
second i'm looking for the stack so are
you creating a new task every time well
i'm not creating a new task i'm creating
a new intent and your pending intent
alright but is that at creating a new so
for example let's say you touch the
widget and yeah you must use the flag
creating your task each time you use a
pending intent or is there another
option oh no that's is that necessarily
true you have to break in stop you have
to create a new task every time you
create a pending attend doesn't seem
like that's a mandatory flag no
definitely um pending intent
I mean that's the concept of merton you
can pass around a lot of people in large
yeah um I mean just as an example in our
design guidelines we have this a dated
section of navigation and it talks about
and this is not great development
specifically around the interaction
design guidelines as the section that
covers how to navigate into your app
deeply into your app from a widget or
notification and the implication is
there is that when you jump into your
app from a widget you shouldn't be
creating a new task every time I you
shouldn't like in your recent when you
touch on reasons you shouldn't see four
or five different instances of your app
no you won't see you you'll see only one
again you will see only one instance on
reasons but each time you create a
pending intent because you're not going
from a context over a specific activity
you must declare the flag new task or
leave that and so on and after few back
and forth in clicks from going to inside
the app and going back to home we're
exiting the app you know finish all the
all the application resources and then
going back to the widget and clicking
again after a few times it just gives me
the exception and trying to find the
stack I started on a text file you just
wanted to see in your spaces that window
here it's fine okay give me a few
minutes and meantime don't get better
hey it's ah it's email along this week
data first yeah hey hell
yeah but money the others he has knee
crush me when I really felt okay that
was wait till to the coat music music
think I child got some feedback control
your speakers up oh I'm thinking let me
just know this it's just a vision which
means his lady oh yeah especially person
automatically pretty good um was it
really that was an intentional that
short cuts aren't part of the new jelly
bean widget design guidelines since they
live in the Woodyard drawer and
four-pointer plus are you basing them
out discouraging their use no I was
intentional if they're left out they're
not widgets their shortcuts the use in
terms of like what the user sees we
happen to place them in the same area
because to a user they may not make a
difference but in terms of you know your
design I mean shortcut design is we
probably should have another guideline
for like like what should be in the app
drawer what you've gone home screen but
it doesn't really belong in the widget
design guidelines are probably being a
separate guideline so we don't treat
them the same although users may kind of
understand them they may have the same
mental model for them but yeah so it's
not intentional if they're not in the
design guidelines altogether but that's
just a matter of priorities whether
whether or not we'll be able to add
things like shortcuts with them so
wouldn't read too much into it yeah I
mean there's still pretty cool or like
you don't put a shortcut to your
contacts and so on that's so pretty cool
and ability you're incredibly useful
so if we ran out of questions we could
always talk about so last night updates
the design guide ships so don't even
seen that thing you should talk about it
remove tell me I haven't to go tell us
starting soon dude Othella tell obscure
one of the things I thought was really
interesting if you now go to the action
bar pattern in the design guide there's
a little bit of talk about the sliding
drawer navigation Hudson which is
gaining some traction so as used in the
Google+ app or the YouTube app and many
apps i doubt like Facebook and Twitter
fight so it's nice to see about starting
to get formalized into a plan for that
that's a start let's sort of that you
know the kind of the reference
implementation that you should look at
another implementation s'alright the
reference app you should look at is the
YouTube app I believe that that's the
screenshot that we show in that time
guideline Google+ add those things a
little differently so highly recommend
will meet youtube and as new pattern so
widgets confirming and acknowledging
help and accessibility say and help
includes tutorials so like when to show
tutorial one not to show tutorial hint
you shouldn't really have to show the
door oh yeah yeah it's generally better
I think yeah the goal is your UI is so
intuitive that you don't need to have
labels and tutorials and so on but you
know it's almost better to have a
one-time tutorial to kind of like
worrying take people if you put a lot of
I'm context behavior rather than you
know a lot of that labels in your UI the
whole time Lansing any other changes you
saw a whip in the desirable I've not a
chastity its back and check them out
tonight a couple of updates over on it's
also what we added for example a lot of
the graphics there had like the zoom and
the neck the Galaxy Nexus we added the
nexus 7 in there for good measure okay
into what in supply such an right no not
the Vice generator that's uh that's been
there but I'll some of those some of the
again just basic high level graphics so
if you're showing the page to say
product managers they may be like oh
what's that is at seven
you go yeah we should plan for seven
somber hey like this what else you got
we got a new visitor in the Hangout hey
there Jenner thanks for coming in oh
you're a bit quiet how much with your
microphones muted yeah he's typing my
audio isn't working you can't hear us
either okay well you can type the
question in the title here you can type
the question in the chat window if you
have one and we can answer it read out
for you you mean x that is there another
question in the moderator oh yes and we
considered yes we have considered it
it's been discussed over and over again
we question okay have we considered
implementing a system which would allow
the user to select if they wish to allow
an individual album to write secure
settings EG enable gps to enable us
developers to make Napa better you x yes
it's been discussed at length many many
times the problem is just that there's
always a trade-off between flexibility
and tractability and you know you give
too many affordances and and all of a
sudden you have chaos basically can't
control the experience in any way so we
I mean I built you can correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe that a lot of these
design choices in the system we're an
attempt to find the right balance
between giving the user enough control
without overwhelming them with choices
and requiring the user to spend all
their time making it picking my new
decisions about the administration of
their device that's a classic examples
that's why you you when you install an
app you either approve or disapprove all
of the permissions all at once when when
you decide to install or not install the
app and then you don't have to revisit
that decision again I remember that I
mean that's the spot on remember that
Android users aren't if I default
or in general techies so one of the
features that you think are oh my god
these are must have features how do you
not have them a lot of those features of
features downright confusing to the
average end user so you're actually
right it's always a trade-off between
making something that that kind of
intimidated alienates users and giving
them enough control all right answer
questions come in on the G+ thread we're
ruling of you should you read ojos no
he's not sometimes I sorry do we have a
bit of diet a better guide to contact
something I say so you're talking about
the sink provider yeah we're essentially
you pump in all the information than the
Android system or I create them into the
contacts that you have as well as any
kind of social media contacts you've got
all those things is that right there's a
great series of blog posts out there
which I often third refer to myself yeah
if you search for ya see 99 to the Sam
Steele the developer for me last of them
he did a series of blog post which is a
which are excellent it's just doing that
those them that I series of odd place
isn't covering all you would just like
to see that level of detail in the
official dogs also there's a sample
fluke adapter which does all that it
does contact syncing it does social
stream ap is as of ice cream sandwich
sync adapter Authenticator those pretty
much all yeah uh-huh Joseph's thanks
looks like we're welcome 11 okay so
going back to this question asked in the
thread so Reuben asks and I I know the
w3c Spector devices API still in flux
but I wonder if there'll be any support
and android 2.2 and 2.3 devices for it
once suspecting fleshed out so the voice
api frozen on the know is browser like
api so that allowing access like the
camera and images and so on as an input
ID and so my initial reactions probably
no because that would require an update
to the browser
and the browser is you know depart the
system image of a device so we're not
able to update that outside of the
firmware update so I would be very
surprised to see that happen first thing
maybe other browsers like so no chrome
is ICS onwards but maybe some other
browsers might be able to offer support
there but not with the stock android
browser all or the webview I don't think
Newt indeed funny no RN and your hands
and you'll see I can't find the trace ok
maybe the next episodes we will be back
next Wednesday soup here yeah you see
that sounds like a guy thing it's
probably placed into a stack overflow
and post and then and link to it in our
moderator that sounds like the right way
to to attack this uh-oh can your hands
ask a question regarding native audio we
have anyone here you can try nice audio
guy you might have lots of places oh yes
okay hi guys hey I'm asking anyway
though this is a question I had some for
a long time now so basically your
documentation says that your support the
openssl audio library for 3d audio and
some stuff around that but if I
implement a listener assault listener
and a sound source inside of open SL and
I try to assign a 3d space to that I get
this ominous error 12 which says this
feature is not supported which is weird
because your documentation says you
support 3d audio but if you try to
implement it it's not working hmm that
is the kind of question I would refer to
the expertise of stack overflow no no I
would say come to thee if you can stay
up for the US office hours tonight and
that some guys from the media team who
would have written our implementation of
that are going to be joining our us
colleagues so you can come
natl time sorry the best place to get up
and asked that question ok so when is
that exactly I said 2 p.m. pacific time
you can see if you go to set in eight
hours from now well I post-op people
come for such life yeah ok thank you
yeah well sorry to yeah serves only a
problem stackoverflow can't help either
no I can see it in the google groups
they have the same thing I try to use
OpenGL ES I get unspotted air 12 and mix
says it depends on which profile flags
the library was compiled with so the
fact that you get an unsupported era for
it means they didn't include the audio
affecting that device be interesting
yeah it's best to just ask the team this
evening ok thank you or ask it in their
moderator you can go through the
developers com link to get to the
moderator and you can just type into
that and then you can watch the video
back tomorrow hopefully they'll answer
it how's something where did he come
from you know there you see I sneak in
when you're not looking rich so I was
just posted the link in the chat window
on the left there to UM to the show for
tonight so you hang out midnight outside
has joined it Anna yeah having the
low-level media team there something
you're gonna help your back home out I
thought you in London this morning I got
back about half an hour ago so I'm where
I've been fighting Chrome OS which
doesn't do hangouts on air up so took me
a bit to get in Oh how's it ok I got a
question for you guys if you want one
yeah yeah feel free to ask I've been
working on an application that basically
turns the user's phone into a gamepad so
you can connect to another device using
bluetooth and so you can play on your
tablet and use your phone as a
controller what's the best way to handle
user-defined layouts is it to use a
canvas view or should I be looking at
using one of the layout managers and
restricting users positions for buttons
and things like that to what the layout
manager can handle
so you want to allow you specify where
all the buttons are on the tablet screen
absolutely yep well so if they want to
have the the control pad thumb pad on
the left or the right they compare and
over speaking is about that you have a
few apps that I've user-defined layouts
I definitely prefer the canvas approach
because what what you end up with when
you try to put things into the layout
manager is invariably great that you can
drop buttons on and it just it's very
limiting so I'm actually play around
with a few remote control absolute you
control your TV when you move buttons
around but the great is it really
conducive especially if you're making a
gamepad and you want to use familiar
patterns like maybe the little diamond
babyeee XY buttons on the side of the
d-pad and these things don't work if you
wind them up in a grid or if they do
they're spaced way too far apart it
would be really awkward so like speaking
as a user I would like your app better
tific use canvas the thing is the
important lunch you have to do like drag
and drop with a non canvas like let's
say you did something similar to look
and absolutely out like a custom layout
that was effectively an absolutely out
the position things like X in my
coordinates as you were dragging to show
you know real-time updates you have to
basically do a layout pass every single
drag rets you have to reach rigger
layout even if it's just within you know
that view just within that view group it
may be pretty slow I guess so I think
just the canvas gonna give you more
flexibility and less pain on all
together nope I'm like am I find like
some of the games which have like a
d-pad input no ones I like the most of
the ones which don't force each other
particular position but they like you
more you put your foot your finger down
it just centers on wherever you place
your fingers I think like the the mat
finger games like shadowgun and dead
trigger do this right and so be kind of
cool life here offer sound like that so
yeah you don't have a physical anchor
point to like locate with your finger
just letting you touch down and where
you move relatively from that will be
Michael just I was thinking along those
lines one of the things that I've got to
take into account is the applications
actually got a window that's a feedback
window from the game it's
off so if you're playing say for example
a games console connected to a TV that
runs android the game itself can
feedback information to just be
displayed on the controller pad so I'm
trying to make sure that they can be
positioned where that information can
still be seen so there might be some
limitations but the idea of centering
and where you push could be quite cool
thanks Nick mmm eyes thanks guys thanks
so especially chairs are a lot of things
pumped into the moderator whilst we've
been talking absolutely a sink provider
behave that syncs files or anything not
accessible using a content resolver I'm
not sure I understand right delivered it
so up I think you got five six months
and then English accent from the book
how should I think about it I got
another question if you need one maybe
okay well think about that one once you
have as a ask the next question go ahead
okay so is it is it possible to override
the GSM stack for implementing your own
phone application that is not only a
dialer but a complete phone for sending
for example gsm codes with out getting a
dialog box as a result uh the only
access to the telephony or you don't
have any any access right to left near
the radio no yeah well you can use sip
right i mean if you're nobody wants to
do that is with the geo sims yeah yeah
awesome write your own android wrong
just wrong yeah yeah sorry outside of
doing your own custom rom okay what the
AOSP rooms it's going to be a tricky
thing else will secure after the sink
provider behave i'm still trying two
parts this question how should a synchro
better behave that syncs files or
anything not accept it so maybe is
anything not excessive leaves new
content resolver maybe he's trying to
block block the content provider or
supervisor being accessible by other
apps yeah
I don't think I think you can do
anything because like x squared equals
fault well then it won't work so this
the sink reviser is a service right it's
a I think what he's trying to ask is if
you got a sink provider that's trying to
synchronize something for your
application you can't feed to it for a
content provider is there a recommended
way of doing it because he's talking
about files but I know there's a method
in a content provider of reading files
is they want to write one right files as
well I yeah I think so first of all
we're not talking about sync adapter
sure it's on my seat providers I think
he's talking about sync adapters but I'm
able to get her to classes oh yeah yeah
I don't know a simple viruses because I
perform same method right we do anything
yeah so sync adapters are the only
correlation doing a way in which sync
adapters interact with content providers
is via the authority it's just a link
right sync adapters don't have we have
to even use a provider at all there's no
there's no api that's specific to sync
adapter just sounding angry yes yeah say
well i think we should move on unless
Marcus can give us a little bit more
context yo Matias hello thanks for
joining us today he says any news on
this issue over kotaku com I'm getting
bad reviews thanks to this issue let's
click on it it says i have set an
android install location to internal
only in my pain at the APK itself
installs to the data absent should
however Google Play installs the app to
man a sec this causes a major problem
access primarily an Android service as
services generated before a second's
mounted it can't find my service and
rude it all associated counselor data
it's a problem with them cope today
became so and it's fixed internally it
just hasn't shipped okay look at the
window gobble uh so I guess after the
function arts is this falls under can't
talk release date
we don't know he'll prolly change but
the news on the issue is that we do know
about it and we know what it's caused by
and it's being worked on sorry about
that i'm gerry more no Johnny that won't
be plus fine but the Play Store updates
separate to Android and the android
phone was so they can push updates out
at anytime they want so as soon as they
fix it and shot i'll push the app also
tested in it all just start working
without you having to make any changes
to your right i'm not sure about that i
think it might actually work the instant
process very very american stores a
thing saying incorrect missions over the
other good news is that in general if
you look at you know Ice Cream Sandwich
look at a guess gingerbread I mean the
very first version that gets released
doesn't stick around for too long looks
like ice cream sandwich trying a
four-point-oh point 14.9 4.2 they're not
really sticking around so much for
point-to-point 34.4 our game a lot of
factions so I mean this is not an
absolute sleeping baby means but just
historically the very first version of a
major desert named release hasn't really
stuck around for too long it's its
immediate successor its release and
longer need something in yeah and 11
month that's what I all developers to
reply to comments no there's no update
on the either sorry Joe that is rolling
out to more developers are I've talked
to a few received in the last week so it
looks like okay or widely available yeah
I think it seems be testing it so I
think yeah Peter you've written a Nevada
testing beta beta test that don't get a
beta with your data that's all I always
run up de y te be beta um M perch is
asking the moderator is there an API for
all the application data out of the play
store I look I pre definitive what's the
best way to have a this is from look II
often in Brazil what's the best way to
have a horizontal scrolling list or grid
on Android since both list view and grid
view our only vertical right you're on
right you're on user view pager
potentially if they just weren't quite
off this depending on how big your going
to have a DM gallery gallery is now
deprecated is it cool is it is it
officially defconn a really nice like
that who's that excitement gallery I got
it can work in some cases but the
physics are all like the touch physics
or else we don't ah could you just put a
linear layout of scroll but it was you
could answer using horizontal scroll the
good thing about lisbian reviews that I
said all right so like if you ever got
10,000 item or the dispute is that
beginner this class is deprecated is no
no supported by the horizontally
scrolling would you so clear or a little
scroll to you in view pager from the
support library so if you want like an
actual horizontal list view that does
all the finger cycling we don't have one
but there are third-party projects yeah
just giggles oh yeah okay android is
attend on that advice AP page area gets
here all the way as well uh 11 other
interesting thing about view pager so
viewpager also does it doesn't do the
recycling but it follows the adapter
pattern so yeah you can implement the
recycling yourself launch it it's not
very complicated one thing I'll say is
that in the recent versions of the
support library I think as of our eighth
or later a view pager I should pager
adapter has this new method called get
page width which lets you create
features that are not hold with you can
create a page that is twenty five
percent of the screen with and so you'll
see four pages at a time or a page that
is fifty percent of unit so you see two
at a time and the touch physics work
well there there's no inertial fling or
anything like that you guys are
interested not don't pay time to
get full next floor next door yeah
actually you advance one page at a time
so it go home
50 you get one yeah look at like items 1
and tune and go one more needs you item
22 in 3d not doing for he do a full wig
go oh actually that made the question
let's check out please minutes via pager
see definitely if it's a 10,000 I most
you can't just do a worship i right the
other thing is if you're quite fancy
with renderscript there's a there's a
example which is called carousel do
that's somewhere who just search for
carousel example android it'll show you
how to do a music of google music style
3d carousel not so much horizontal as it
is three-dimensional but yet another
hundred linked to google i/o tar from
the spirit yeah something like yeah but
right there's two versions of the render
script carousel the flashy
understandable and quite boring a one
that's 3d looks amazing the sample code
in that yeah the sample code for render
script has as one version maybe I'll to
understand but the music player while i
think is twenty thousand lines of
renderscript in one file one daughter in
silence was it's meant to be it's meant
to be like flexible customizable right
where the right the higher level API you
just specify basic things like it don't
go to the doctor i respond yet dad beat
dragon unless you want your eyes yes sir
that's the right hazel course it's not
worth learning this decade yeah so there
was some checking on a sidebar about
good wireframing tools which i know is
one of the Romans favorite topic so I'd
say pencil and paper or fluid UI and the
two I don't tend to use haven't either
we have official stencils or omnigraffle
dobby fireworks then we fireworks is
very good if you wanna do interactive
wireframes like where you can click a
button and actually flip to the page
that that button would lead to low light
shading cuz file access also there's
Photoshop stencil so I mean outside of
the official stencils kit for fireworks
photoshop and omnigraffle if you use any
other tool a pencil for firefox ignition
they just added a android
no stencil kit built in or just
available for download and fluid UI also
comes with a with an injured foot once
again excellent questions flying in
there we've got even is left so I'm not
running at rhythm all but you'll see who
is so what my is dialogue this demo
select whatever has asked is there a way
of showing progress on a dialogue
recommitted to know building web page
personally I like a window feature movie
on the same as if you window feature
just shown the web page loading progress
on the top of the dialog yeah visit the
title or something like that you have to
implement it yourself so the window
features specific to activate leaders
like for example dialogues can't even
have action bars that's partly because
of the same for the same reason see dr.
just have your own progress blog update
yourself so the best way to implement it
is to add a progress bar above the web
view and show the progress as you go
along with loading the URL yeah um in
general I mean you're saying what view
inside of a dialogue and that's already
kind of starting to scare me ya know
it's a it's a publication web you can
see it I don't know it's just a level
but yeah yeah Commissioner just showing
the user you can see it oxmo so in
general don't be afraid of a full screen
windows me users don't users have awful
memory but not not that awful like Billy
yeah I have a full window showing the
progress bar and everything but i think
it's it's more fluent to the user and
more comprehensive to show when you
using when using two panes then i'm
clicking on the left pane and showing
the dialogue and then after setting
dialog or making that the authentication
then the right pane shows the content
you want to
go and head from for the user okay I
think it's a better UI flow for the user
okay yeah so that case you publish them
to make your own progress bar yeah as
joe says inside shabaab just having a
linear linear layout with a progress bar
about the web feed myself one thing is
that the progress bar has built-in
padding so they'll be like actually on
ICS and even money convey the tail and I
guess the head of the progress bar is
actually a glow so it has some built-in
petting to account for that so if usual
in your layout and your web view will
appear below the globe maybe do a family
outfit yeah you may want to have a
preemie out and have the progress bar
neatly like the middle of the progress
bar in line with the top edge of the
webview let's flip chrome and the plaid
the buildin browser good okay thanks I'm
searching for Boyd a dingy what it was
is twitter client for android right are
you on the boy teen there John when you
can't talk can you sorry you have to do
my cancer comes up front and mine oh I
know 20 results are people avoid as a
warrior and I've got there quick
question that I wanted to ask and where
can I find Google Wallet I try to find
America no we don't have why not you
want from out here hey because the
fields and carry it mms i'm asking
because it's actually started walking in
his lab some shops say some people most
to actually pay with google wallet which
is quite funny it's all based on
mastercard paypass which is a global
standard so you can do it in the UK as
well in mcdonalds and places like that
yeah so yeah what you need to do if
that's where I did if you can get hold
of a Galaxy Nexus or a device for which
the stock firmware is produced you can
put the u.s. firmware from the google
developers site on it put a US sim in
the
phone and you'll get full working Google
Wallet functionality if it doesn't have
a US sim in it won't work you just like
picked up on my trip to the States yeah
we tried a few times on google i/o and
then we found out that you need to yeah
I sleep question photo/brian buying his
Greg's pasties that is nexus 7 but I
tried it from the market website in
sorry the play website you know the full
website on the pc and I faked I even
faked my IP so I can access to the US
tour and I didn't find it there so I can
only do it for my galaxy nexus you want
us to teach you how to hack the Play
stores no I said I didn't even find it
broke outside yeah but IIT isn't I don't
think I p is the only signal we use the
determinations racist or different ones
now so you can just break the but
isn't while it is location so that is
maybe the reason why it's not available
in the Play Store it's it's available by
the Play Store but it's triggered off of
the same inside the device so unless
you've got a US carrier sim in the
device see your chances about installing
and being usable or absolutely none yeah
but if you have a nexus 7 tablet then
you don't have a seam so basically it's
based on the location the Play Store app
yeah I'm gonna say this isn't it android
development that's smart i wonder if
there's anything else Jeanette's two
minutes does anything anyone in the
Hangout have anything that i really want
to say in the last two minutes thank you
very much for joining us first of all
thank you and one last question how can
i get my app featured what is the best
let's have to check now if anyone asks I
to hang out we like to drink it that's
to every single week yeah I know I know
just so you can drink the double how do
i get like Google+ page verified
a good thing for the future if you think
you look great up is may be submitted to
the Friday review and the Friday clinic
okay my bad had to rewire bring right so
yeah that's a good way to get in front
of people like another way it's just
like how are we promoting at the moment
basically we're doing some campaigns on
different and websites and different
stores like on samsung store on the
Amazon and so and so on with affiliates
and we want to see how to get our appt
featured in the play store because
that's the best way to get our app and
be more visible luckily we were we
already have more unlike six and a half
million downloads already Wow yeah and
one what Seattle fufu what oh boo hoo
ever like to do a video play the video
conferencing yeah double OD double o
social video chat sorry yeah I know that
yeah that's the one isn't there a
checklist somewhere of things that
people should do to help it over you
know what not to do to not get not
feature because that was a google i/o
blog post by Natasha blog that talks
about image guilin with your play
listing guidelines like your feature
graphic your your titles or descriptions
there are some things that are just very
simple things to make their you have oh
we don't actually offer the finna give
list of do XYZ you will get featured but
we provide a wealth of information on
things that will get you not featured
and so is using a knife I'm layout right
and then I'm 0 over 0 you need to clear
before about a featuring even becomes
consideration so Dan Galpin and in Lewis
David talk at I oh that was any games
but a lot of it is a what ten things
every game club
right but a good chunk of that was
things that will get you not featured on
on Google Play also like like I said
Natasha box post on boson like the I
think the resources that you use and
like looking good and we will play yeah
like the dimensions for your for your
promotional graduation so I think you
like one one mistake a lot of people do
is they have to upload a small
application recommend me they're tall
they have to upload a larger banner size
one so they just blow up the first one
to skew blurry mess that we would never
put on the front page of Google Play
that was voice as they say hey it's 1024
pixels wide like I put in height so so
I'll scream shout our IDE look like tons
of texts in there and when we want to
feature the application because that's
going to get like shrunk down this big
on the website to this big on the phone
like it's just a legible so think aloud
but i would say from a two-minute look
at your screen shots that a little bit
of application of Android design
guidelines would certainly help any
potential featuring yeah yeah I'm we're
doing a redesign for all there because
the main issue was before I got to the
youth yes anyone else that's right most
of the features from the iphone in order
to do a cross-platform oleum you know
when you want to do a fluent a
cross-platform you I and when I came to
move we started working on the design
guidelines and all that and that's where
we were doing right now we're
implementing a new version to be done to
be published in the market in the next
few weeks and that will be a better
design and hopefully the next version
will be even better so that sounds a
great like so once you have this new
version kind of launched maybe you can
turn a big push around that so if you
try and get you know pick up some and
some play in the media and maybe get
some advertising around the application
and then submit to the you know the
Friday clinic as well and we can take a
look at it so if you're trying like time
all the push around your relaunch that
could be a good time okay thank you
alright well we've gone over time but
thank you all very much for joining it
today those of you on YouTube as well
we've been watching the stream thanks
joining its massive crowd that's all six
of us today over here in London and
we'll see you all again same time next
week cheers babe I write my leg